[Music]
with the end of year four coming along
and season 11 on the horizon The
Division II team at massive
entertainment have released a public
test server or pts to let us try and
break some of the new additions coming
in season 11. year 5 will be bringing us
some new seasons in the new descent game
mode but these aren't being featured in
the pts for now Focus has been placed on
various balances as well as new gear
weapons Exotics and set items I've put a
few hours into testing these out and in
this video I'm going to share my
thoughts around what I've managed to
muck around with so far
before I get into it please remember
that this is a test server it's very
likely that everything I talk about here
will be tweaked and adjusted before the
final release after all this is the
purpose of the PTS
the pts has been going for a few days
now but this is the last update before
year 5 begins so don't be expecting too
much realistically we're receiving one
new brand set one new gear set two new
named items two new named weapons one
new weapon Talent one new exotic weapon
one new exotic item a few PVP quality of
life updates and a growing list of game
performance and other updates
immediately we can see that the focus
has been placed on marksman rifles and
status effects to a lesser extent with
this update
both the brand set and the gear set
provide bonuses to marksman rifles and
headshots
this is pretty standard the last one or
two have been focused on skills so I'm
actually pretty stoked to see some
attention being brought to the sniper
builds however when comparing my current
One-Shot sniper build to this new Hot
Shot gear set after a number of tweaks I
actually wasn't getting very high
numbers
I would say that this is a much easier
way to build high damage snipers and the
extra armor is useful but I think I
prefer my original build to what this
new set is offering like I said I expect
we'll see some tweaks here not that I
want this to be the only thing to run
while using a marksman rifle I just like
it to be a little more relevant if I'm
sniping I'm running a glass Cannon to
get the most out of my shots the armor
is nice but at high difficulties with a
low rate of fire this seems a little
redundant
but the new brand set Habsburg guard
there seems to be a little something
different going on here
it starts off similar with headshot
damage and Marksman rifle damage but
then it moves them to status effects
which seems like a weak three-piece
bonus to me
both the new named pieces to the set
also delve into status effects
the chest has a 20 second cooldown so I
don't really see this being too popular
over other options but the backpack
could be interesting with the right
crowd control or status effect build
the sacrum Imperium is the new exotic
variation of the g28 Marksman rifle it
has the talent the Trap summing it up
you can tag up to a maximum of 10
enemies by viewing them in your sights
killing one of the marked targets with a
headshot will apply a 10 second burn
status effect and 50 movement speed
decrease on all other targets
this is interesting but it falls into
the same trap as most of the other
exotic weapons as being a little too
situational and underwhelming to be of
any real use in the long term targets
need to be held in your sights for over
two seconds before they are marked and
when everything is running around and
shooting at you this is a long time
this is really only useful as an ambush
weapon before the hostiles have been
eggrolled but then again it takes so
long to Mark a group that I'm not sure
that I'd bother
however I must say the design of this
weapon is awesome
the new named weapons are the prophet
revolver and The Relic g28 maximum rifle
I absolutely love their perfect talent
but just not on these weapons
killing an enemy with a headshot
guarantees the next shot will be a
critical headshot
if I could put this on the white death
or some other hard-hitting sniper I
would be a very happy man but the
non-perfect version of this Talent is a
little different
after killing an enemy with a headshot
the next shot landed on any enemy will
be a guaranteed headshot
I'm sure people will find a use for this
perhaps when using a controller but for
me the guaranteed critical hit was what
made this Talent stick out
imagine a sniper build where you can
focus on just headshot damage and
critical head damage completely ignoring
critical hit chance
there have been a number of PVP quality
of life changes mainly relating to
skills more specifically gemmers and the
shrapnel trap
I don't play this game for its unique
PVP experience so I can't really comment
on these but one thing that has been an
area of contention across the community
is the addition of a couple of raid
Exotics into the dark Zone loot pool
there are actually three Exotics being
added but the big horn is already
available outside the raids
I didn't realize how divided the
community really was around this until I
stumbled across a couple of long threads
that were getting very heated
I can actually see the argument from
both sides but I'm not really that
passionate about either I agree there
should be some unique rewards for those
who complete the raid
but if that's all it was people would
only complete the raid once anyway there
is obviously something else raid players
are gaining from completing this game
mode
I'm someone who doesn't have all the
raid Exotics not through a lack of
trying it's just very difficult for me
to find a team of seven other players to
run through it they're able to work with
my difficult time zone but at the same
time I'm really not that worried about
missing out on a couple of different
weapons
the addition of these two weapons into
the dark Zone likely won't impact how
often I frequent the area
regardless of how small this update is
there is one thing that I'm very much
looking forward to the ninja bike
messenger bag exotic backpack
those of you who played through the
division one should remember this it was
the most sought after exotic in the game
at one stage before classified six came
along and ruined all the build diversity
this piece of gear acts as a filler to
complete the requirements towards
unlocking gear set bonuses the reason
this is a game changer is that it can be
used to complete requirements for more
than one set at a time while only taking
up one slot
this will mean that we're able to unlock
more bonuses than we've been able to up
until now it essentially opens up a
whole new tier of build options
unfortunately this isn't available in
the pts but expect to see a huge number
of build videos coming up from YouTubers
in the future as they redefine all of
your favorite builds
I'm not sure how long this pts goes for
or if we'll be seeing multiple different
tiers like we've seen in different ones
but if I had to guess I'd say this won't
be a long one March marks the end of
year four so they'll be wanting to have
everything sorted well before then
I need to repeat what I said earlier
everything I've shown here is subject to
change while this gives a good
indication of what is to come individual
talents and specs are likely to be
adjusted following the end of the PTS
I hope you found this video useful and
I'll catch you in the next one cheers
[Music]
[Music]